[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay una pieza que no termina de encajar
en todo este puzzle del golpe de estado
de pregosin a estas alturas seguro que
habréis leído todo tipo de análisis y un
sinfín de vídeos sobre el tema pero
todavía queda una pregunta por responder
qué le prometió lucasenko afrigo sin
exactamente poneos en la piel del líder
de Wagner por un momento estamos a punto
de entrar en Moscú y de repente nos
llama Alexander lucasenco y nos dice
date media vuelta y vente conmigo a
Bielorrusia y no te preocupes que nadie
te va a matar de verdad os fiarías
quiero decir si algo caracteriza
precisamente a Vladimir Putin es que no
le tiembla el pulso a la hora de
intentar matar a sus opositores y ojo
que esto no es un término metafórico
sino que se lo digan Alexa y naval ni
que estuvo a punto de morir envenenado y
a tantos otros que no tuvieron tanta
suerte y si hay una persona en este
momento a la que Putin le gustaría ver
bajo tierra Ese es precisamente pregosin
que le hace pensar este hombre que está
seguro en Bielorrusia que no deja de ser
Aliado de Moscú Pues bien aquí llega la
hipótesis que planteamos en este vídeo y
si estuviéramos ante una jugada maestra
de lukashenko por el momento todos
estamos de acuerdo en que ha sido uno de
los mayores beneficiados en este intento
de golpe de estado Pero cómo de
beneficiado vamos a decirlo de una forma
aún más osada y sin realidad Vladimir
Putin ha sido el pagafantasmas o el SIM
de todo este asunto y ni siquiera lo
sabe agarrados a la Silla porque en el
vídeo de hoy vamos a tocar muchas claves
que van a hacer que veáis el golpe de
pregosing con unos ojos muy distintos y
ojo porque vamos a hablar de armas
nucleares dentro vídeo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
uno de nuestros pasatiempos favoritos en
internet es seguir a los protagonistas
progresos en Twitter Todavía siguen
pensando que Vladimir Putin es un genio
de la estrategia un campeón del ajedrez
en cuatro dimensiones y con tal de
justificar que Putin es semejante genio
son capaces de hacer auténticas piruetas
de gimnasia mental atentos a este meme
que ha circulado estos días claro Ahora
resulta que en realidad prigó sin estaba
siguiendo los dictados de Putin para
terminar a 100 kilómetros de gif jugada
maestra es que no lo veis
vamos a ver angelicos míos si Putin
quisiera enviar las tropas de Wagner a
la frontera con Kid no habría necesitado
fingir un golpe de estado y arriesgar su
posición interna además qué sentido
tendría verdad que energía Pero qué
sentido tiene volver a intentar tomar
Kingston 25.000 tropas es decir en
febrero 2022 con casi 200.000 soldados
armados hasta los dientes hicieron el
ridículo y ahora con muchas menos tropas
van a mejorar el resultado pues menuda
jugada de ajedrez vamos a ver mis
queridos fanboys de Putin entiendo que
la fe mueve montañas Pero esto ya es
como un chiste es que da igual como lo
mires El golpe de estado de pregón y no
tiene absolutamente ninguna buena
lectura para Rusia ninguna podemos
discutir sobre si es bueno o es malo
para Ucrania pero está claro que Putin
ha sido el mayor perjudicado de todo
esto pero eso ya lo sabemos la pregunta
ahora es Quién ha sido el mayor
beneficiado Pues en este caso Tampoco
hay muchas dudas Alexander lucasenco El
dictador de Bielorrusia por el momento
ya se ha elegido como el Salvador de la
Rusia de Putin Pero y si en realidad se
ha estado aprovechando del descontrol
Putin por resumir esta historia en
términos tuiteros antes pensábamos que
Putin era un chat ahora Estamos viendo
que en realidad es un SIM de manual o
como decimos en España un pagafantas Y
diréis por qué Por qué decimos que
lucasenko se ha beneficiado tanto de
este golpe de estado Por qué decimos que
el desastre para Putin puede ser aún
mayor de lo que pensábamos y porque
decimos que le pone en una posición de
pagafantas frente a Bielorrusia hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes si te gusta lo que hacemos y
quieres ayudarnos a crecer puedes
sumarte a nuestra comunidad de patreon
además de contribuir con este proyecto
recibirás también un montón de contenido
extra como el boletín las claves de la
semana nuevos vídeos exclusivos y
merchandising muchas gracias a los que
ya nos estáis echando una mano formando
parte de esta comunidad y a los que no
os dejo el enlace en la descripción y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
un dictador muy resiliente
para quien no lo conozca Alexander
lukasenko es el dictador que domina
Bielorrusia con mano de hierro desde
1994 uno de los pocos dictadores que ni
siquiera se esfuerzan ponerse una careta
de democrático de hecho ha llegado a
presumir de su condición de dictador con
frases míticas como esta es mejor ser
dictador que gay Alexander lucashenko
Pues bien cuando empezó La Guerra de
Ucrania todos esperábamos que la
economía de Bielorrusia colapsara
pensando así Bielorrusia también ha sido
sancionada por occidente pero a
diferencia de Rusia no tienen ni gas ni
petróleo la principal exportación de
este país de 9 millones de habitantes es
los fertilizantes eso y algo de
tecnología por ejemplo pues son al
videojuego World of tanks pues está
hecho en Bielorrusia O al menos lo
estaba la empresa más grande de
videojuegos de Bielorrusia abandona el
país y Rusia el desarrollador del juego
de guerra World of tanks cierra sus
estudios y traslada la operativa de los
juegos para que os hagáis una idea desde
las protestas del año 2020 más de 20.000
trabajadores del sector it han
abandonado Bielorrusia cifras son una
auténtica barbaridad si tenemos en
cuenta que esta industria concreta Tiene
un total de entre 60 y 100.000
trabajadores vamos que Bielorrusia está
perdiendo a más de 20.000 de sus
trabajadores más cualificados a estas
alturas podemos decir que los únicos
sectores económicos que quedan vivos en
el país son los fertilizantes y alguna
que otra metalurgia y el problema es
cómo pueden exportar estos productos
Bielorrusia no tiene salida al mar y
antes incluso de que empezara la Guerra
de Ucrania lituania ya les había
prohibido utilizar el puerto de claipeda
el puerto de claipeda era la principal
salida de los fertilizantes de
Bielorrusia sin eso la economía entera
estaba al borde del colapso de hecho en
un solo año las exportaciones de
Bielorrusia hasta la Unión Europea
cayeron en un 45% de hecho fijaos en
esta gráfica si os fijáis tras el
anuncio del cierre del puerto de
lituania a Bielorrusia la divisa del
país cae después llega la Guerra de
Ucrania y las sanciones de occidente y
se desploma y de repente
en julio de 2022 vuelve a remontar casi
de forma milagrosa sí es cierto desde
entonces sigue cayendo lentamente por
supuesto los controles de capital han
jugado un papel clave Pero estos no han
sido su único escudo
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea algunas
predicciones apuntaban a que el pib de
Bielorrusia caerían un 10% en 2022 pero
sin embargo Esta caída se quedó en un
simple 4,7%, que sigue siendo una crisis
enorme pero no es el agujero que cabría
esperar y diréis por qué Qué ha hecho
Bielorrusia para evitar un Armagedón
económico pues lo podemos resumir en una
frase Rusia al rescate habéis oído bien
Rusia ha hecho todo lo posible por
ayudar a su Aliado
[Música]
por ejemplo he accedido todos sus
puertos para que puedan retomar las
exportaciones no solo eso Minsk va a
poder construir su propio Puerto en
territorio ruso gracias a esto Pueden
seguir exportando sus fertilizantes a
países como China o Brasil pero no sólo
eso Rusia también ha ofrecido
generosísimas líneas de crédito al país
y como buen Aliado le ha dado
preferencia para las importaciones es
decir que los rusos ahora importan más
productos bielorrusos que antes
concretamente hablamos de un 40% más que
antes de la guerra y como os podéis
imaginar todo esto ha servido para
absorber el shock que supuso la caída de
las exportaciones a la Unión Europea y
por supuesto todo esto también con unos
precios de gas y petróleo que son la
envidia del resto de Europa y creedme
esto lo han notado y mucho todos los
ciudadanos bielorrusos fijaos sin ir más
lejos en los precios de la gasolina
dicho de otra forma que sí Bielorrusia
lo está pasando mal pero no tan mal como
que habría esperar y todo esto es
gracias a Rusia pero esperado momento
porque no solo hablamos de economía
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
un dictador con pies de barro
A diferencia de Putin lucasenco sí tiene
una oposición conocida y organizada Y es
que veréis en el año 2020 celebraron
elecciones Es verdad que fueron unas
elecciones tan fraudulentas como que
habría esperar pero con una diferencia Y
es que en este caso sí que había una
candidata en la oposición a lucasenco es
ver lana tijanos y esta mujer sigue
consiguió galvanizar un movimiento de
oposición que se tradujo en protestas
masivas contra La dictadura por supuesto
Alexander lucasen correspondió con la
brutal represión que cabría esperar de
hecho atentos a esta gráfica
sin embargo ahora mismo tijera ya está
en el exilio en lituania desde ahí está
organizando un movimiento de oposición
muy bien articulado para que os hagáis
una idea tienen incluso una app que se
llama New belaus Y desde ahí coordinan a
todos los bielorrusos en el exilio
Mientras tanto lucashenko no tiene mucho
poder para evitar un levantamiento serio
para que os hagáis una idea el ejército
bielorruso está en unas condiciones muy
parecidas a las que tenía el ucraniano
antes de 2014 armamentos soviético
muchísima corrupción y muy efectivos
para que os hagáis una idea se calcula
que el ejército bielorruso está formado
por apenas unos 50.000 soldados y eso no
es todo de estas tropas estima que solo
17.000 estarían actualmente entrenados y
preparados para el combate Y eso siendo
muy generosos muchas Fuentes reducen aún
más esta de estimación a una horquilla
de entre 6000 Y 10.000 efectivos Y para
colmo ni siquiera está muy claro que
sean 100% leales a lucasencos
de hecho una de las razones por las que
este país no ha enviado tropas Ucrania
es porque el dictador sabe que no puede
presionar a sus generales sí es cierto
Bielorrusia ha permitido que las tropas
rusas pasen por su territorio nacional
pero hasta ahí termina toda la ayuda que
le prestan y de hecho atentos a esta
noticia las fuerzas rebeldes en
Bielorrusia cortan parcialmente la ruta
de ferrocarril que lleva a Ucrania ya lo
veis lucasenco ni siquiera puede evitar
sabotajes en su propio territorio Así
que la pregunta es cómo se puede
mantener una dictadura con semejantes
pies de barro la en una frase Rusia al
rescate Vladimir Putin ha ofrecido
enviar asistencia militar Para apoyar al
presidente de Bielorrusia Alexander
lucasenco mientras 200.000 manifestantes
se reúnen para pedir su dimisión esta
fue la ayuda de Putin cuando lucasenco
estaba contra las cuerdas en el año 2020
pero Mirad lo que están haciendo ahora y
en los Rusia comienza a recibir los
envíos de armas nucleares rusas habéis
oído bien Bielorrusia Ya está bajo el
paraguas nuclear de Rusia pero no solo
es para cuando veáis este vídeo
Bielorrusia ya tendrá armas nucleares
para defender su territorio y todo esto
sin siquiera tener que desarrollarlas
ellos mismos La pregunta es y todo este
apoyo sale gratis evidentemente no Cuál
es el precio Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
estaremos juntos algún día
[Música]
en 1991 Bielorrusia se independizó de la
unión soviética pero
Moscú nunca terminó de creerse que este
país iba a ser libre y soberano por
mucho tiempo ya en 1999 con como
presidente Bielorrusia firmó un acuerdo
para el llamado estado de la unión esto
significa que algún día Rusia y
Bielorrusia se unirían en una entidad
supranacional llamada estado de la unión
que ha visto Así suena como una especie
de Unión Europea verdad creo que ya os
imaginaréis que no es así el nombre
sugiere algo estilo un matrimonio pero
pensadlo bien Esto de aquí es Rusia el
país más grande del mundo en territorio
con más de 140 millones de habitantes y
esto de ahí es Bielorrusia claramente no
era un matrimonio entre iguales sin un
contrato de su misión pura y dura un
intento de que Bielorrusia se
convirtiera en una región rusa más y hay
una cosa que tenemos que tener muy clara
en esta historia lucasenko puede ser un
tirano malvado y despiadado pero no es
tonto y no está dispuesto a perder su
poder Así que estos dos países firmaron
el acuerdo sí pero desde entonces no se
ha dado ningún paso en la dirección de
unirse no sólo eso Putin ha llegado a
presionar a lucashenko usando su mayor
arma económica gas y petróleo y el
dictador bielorruso ha llegado a
plantarle cara llegando a hacer cosas
como esta 14 de febrero de 2020
Bielorrusia amenaza con desviar el gas
ruso que se quiera enviar a Europa
habéis oído bien Esto no es ninguna
broma Bielorrusia llegó a amenazar con
robar el gas ruso que se enviaba a
Europa y que pasaba por su territorio
sin embargo esto es del año 2020
concretamente de antes de las protestas
contra lucashenko en este momento Este
dictador pensaba que tenía una posición
de fuerza pero luego llegaron las Macro
protestas y en mins se dieron cuenta de
que un dictador solo tiene poder si
cuenta con músculo militar que le apoye
sin eso es que no hay nada que hacer Así
que cuando lucasenco se vio contra las
cuerdas no lo quedó otro remedio que
bajarse los pantalones delante de Putin
y decir lo que tú quieras papi y así ha
sido la relación entre estos dos países
en los últimos dos años llegando
extremos como este documentos filtrados
muestran la estrategia de Rusia para
anexionarse Bielorrusia en 2030 todo
esto explica que Putin no tenga ningún
problema en regalar Estas armas
nucleares el ukashenko a fin de cuentas
tarde o temprano Bielorrusia va a ser
parte de Rusia verdad O tal vez no aquí
llega el plot twist que nadie se
esperaba ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
tienes el pagafantas aquí
24 de junio de 2023 Los mercenarios del
grupo Wagner se plantan a unos cientos
de kilómetros de Moscú en cuestión de
horas los vuelos para marcharse de la
ciudad Se agotan porque los moscovitas
están aterrados por lo que parece el
inicio de una guerra civil hablamos de
casi 25.000 tropas sublevadas que están
avanzando por territorio ruso como Pedro
por su casa y os preguntaréis Podrían
haber llegado a tomar Moscú lo más
probable es que no pero está claro que
de haber seguido con la marcha habría
sido un auténtico baño de sangre y
entonces cuando Putin estaba realmente
contra las cuerdas ocurre lo siguiente
lo que Vais a ir ahora es literalmente
la conversación telefónica que el propio
lucasenco afirma que tuvo con Putin pero
como vamos a liquidar a los amotinados
vamos a hablar con pericos y sus
comandantes por lo menos mira sasa que
es que no me coge ni el teléfono que es
que ya no quiere hablar conmigo y
entonces es cuando llega lucasenco y
llama por teléfono a pregosin minutos
más tarde Wagner dice que se retira de
Moscú y que se va a Bielorrusia y horas
más tarde el kremlin dice lo siguiente
Rusia retira las acusaciones criminales
contra prigoxin tras la rebelión de
Wagner Durante los siguientes días prigó
sin está en paradero desconocido y a la
vez Rusia dice que todos Los mercenarios
de Wagner que no participaron en el
motín tienen las puertas abiertas en el
ejército regular pero recordad que
pregosin tenía entre su mando cuando da
golpe a entre 20.000 y 25.000 militares
y diréis pueden ser reales unos
mercenarios pues probablemente mucho más
de lo que podríamos pensar
entrada le han apoyado en su intento de
golpe de estado Pero además pensado una
cosa rigosin ha reclutado a exoficiales
del ejército ruso pagándole sueldos
estratosféricos pero no sólo eso también
ha reclutado a expresidiarios y diréis
puede ser Leal un expresidiario pues La
respuesta es que sí y mucho hablamos de
gente con vidas totalmente destruidas
gente sin familia ni futuro a los que un
buen día rigosin Les ofreció una segunda
oportunidad pasar de ser criminales a
ser Héroes de Su patria a lo largo de la
historia hemos visto montones de cuerpos
de élite que se han creado con una
filosofía muy parecida dicho de otra
forma que no está solo y lucasenko lo
sabe Y por eso lucasenco no solo está
recibiendo al líder de los wagneres su
país sino a todos sus equipos nos van a
informar sobre las armas Cuáles
funcionaron cuáles no funcionaron y las
tácticas y el armamento Y cómo atacar
cómo defenderse esto no tiene precio y
esto es lo que necesitamos tomar de los
wagneritas Alexander lukashenko y lo
cierto Es que razón no le falta Los
mercenarios de Wagner unas auténticas
bestias responsables de las torturas más
salvajes que os podáis imaginar pero una
cosa es cierta son prácticamente los
únicos que han logrado alguna Victoria
para el bando ruso en Ucrania y esto
explica noticias como esto Bielorrusia
está construyendo un campo para los
miembros de Wagner trasladados ya lo
veis lucasenco no está perdiendo el
tiempo y alguno dirá Pero de dónde van a
sacar el dinero para seguir manteniendo
estos guerreros a fin de cuentas sin los
contratos que tenía Wagner gremlin quién
les va a pagar el sueldo
Pues bien si sois veteranos seguidores
de visualpolitik ya sabéis que Wagner No
solo está en Ucrania también está muy
activo en África donde no cobran en
dinero sino en especie Wagner controla
varias Minas en África hablamos de oro y
otros recursos por valor de miles de
millones de dólares y todo ese dinero ya
no va a llegar al kremlin sino a los
bolsillos de Wagner dicho de otra forma
es muy probable que las cuentas de
pregon estén tan saneadas como las del
mismísimo Putin
Y diréis dónde está precocina ahora
Exacto en mins la capital de Bielorrusia
y que necesitaba lucasenco para
plantarle caraputín Exacto músculo
militar antes decíamos que Bielorrusia
solo cuenta con un ejército de menos de
50.000 unidades activas Y que además
están mal entrenadas y mal armadas Pues
bien Ahora acaban de recibir entre
20.000 y 25.000 tropas con experiencia
de combate y bien entrenadas y ya sé lo
que me diréis alguno pero Fonseca quien
garantiza que pregosin vaya a serle a la
lucasenco La respuesta es las
circunstancias Wagner no puede volver a
Rusia pero necesitan estar en algún
lugar pocos países les van a ofrecer
asilo salvo Bielorrusia es decir que por
el momento lucasenko y pregosi tienen
muy buenas razones para llevarse bien y
por supuesto cuando Putin se ha dado
cuenta de esta jugada Ya es demasiado
tarde que Rusia ha estado simpeando a
Bielorrusia durante años dinero armas
nucleares y ahora un ejército privado la
pregunta ahora es para vosotros sí que
necesitando Bielorrusia Rusia vamos a
ver cómo la tensión entre estos dos
países se vuelve a recrudecer intentará
Putin retirar las armas nucleares que ya
ha puesto en Bielorrusia Quién tiene más
poder en este momento Putin o lucasenco
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones tampoco
olvidéis pasaros por nuestra comunidad
en patreon si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]